hey what's going on everybody most of
you here watch all the videos that I'll
upload so if you remember about a week
ago I said in one of those videos that I
had this big announcement to make for
the next giveaway well today is going to
be that day because the package that I
ordered has arrived
and I'm going to be giving away the
entire blu-ray series to one lucky
subscriber
that's right seasons one through six on
blu-ray one of you will win so stay
tuned until the end of this video to
find out about all the details about how
you can win now let's get into today's
video but there's something that needs
to be addressed first because there are
actually people out there that are
making Theory videos that are based 100%
from the plot leaked not only are they
using both plot leaks but they're
actually claiming it as their theory
that they created which is absolutely a
lie you guys know that I love to talk
about spoilers especially when they are
backed up with some evidence but I can
never take stuff from this leagues and
claim it as my own theory especially
when there's been no evidence of some of
that [ __ ] actually coming true so in
spite of that I want to talk about some
stuff without using any evidence we have
gotten from the spoilers in fact there
really hasn't been any officially
spoiled information about this character
nothing has been proven at least and one
thing about this plot leak that has
bothered me ever since I read it was the
lack of information about Littlefinger
out of all the stuff it says it has less
than a few sentences about little
thinker which is a major red flag to me
you mean to tell me that Littlefinger is
going to sit at Winterfell for the
entire season until his death at the
very end there is no way in hell that is
accurate and I think the evidence from
previous seasons is the best evidence to
use to find out what Littlefinger will
do next
or what will happen a little finger next
and I can see little finger dying by the
end of next season but it's not going to
go down like everyone thinks and I think
there is a way that songs of stark can
kill two birds with one stone so let me
briefly go over how the show ended to
set up where I think it's going to go
next which would be a little bit more
interesting in my opinion than songs and
arias sitting at Winterfell and
bickering with each other
now that saunas aren't Liza's dead that
has left her song sweet Robin in power
of the veil but we all know that as of
right now
Littlefinger is actually the one calling
the shots Littlefinger has a lot of
influence over sweet Robin just like he
did with his mother Liza and for our
time he even had influence over songs oh
but things have changed drastically and
Littlefinger will not be talking his way
out of this one
and Littlefinger has made a few critical
errors in the last couple episodes and
he assumed that by him providing the
Vale Army that was enough to get him
something in return as if that would he
raised songs his memory of everything he
has done
now although Littlefinger brought the
Vale army personally songs that could
have easily cut off his connection to
sweet Robin one mention of how her on
Liza died and Lord Royce would have
taken pleasure and dismembering
Littlefinger himself in sweet Robin
already said on his own that sawn - it's
his cousin and he should help her then
Littlefinger agreed so I believe songs
that could have got the Vale there
what's the without Littlefinger but
little fingers ego has gotten in the way
and he thinks he is so smart that he can
always find a way or create a way to get
what he wants or get out of anything
that he has done and he thought that by
telling songs that he wants her by his
side on the Iron Throne that she was
just going to fall head-over-heels for
his [ __ ] but that's not going to
happen anymore picture me
on the iron from thank you by my side
[Music]
the pretty picture
[Music]
use of this battle will spread quickly
through the seven kingdoms of the cloud
for house stock for all to hear
declared for other houses before Lord
Venice has never stopped you from
serving yourself
he was even cocky enough to think that
what he said was sweet enough for her
kiss but songs are shut that down real
quick not only does she not want to be
with little thinker but I think she
doesn't even desire being queen like she
once did
Sansa has learned harshly about what
comes with the Iron Throne she even said
herself that she was stupid for thinking
life could be this sweet little fairy
tale with princes and princesses
which is why Sansa had no problem with
Jon becoming king when king in the north
was echoed through the halls of
Winterfell Songza was happy as hell for
John she was proud of John Littlefinger
said he declared for how stark
for everyone to hear but songs they even
shut that down knowing that he will
still do whatever is in his best
interest even though we know Ned Stark
is not John's father
I think songs are now looks at John it
can see her father and John in ways
other than just physical appearance
which is why songs a hand made John the
top coat just like Ned used to wear what
songs a will lack from having her dad
around she will now gain from John that
warmth of having family around that
protection and in return Sansa will want
to protect John which leads to
Littlefinger second mistake the look he
gave John when he was named king
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
shawne's and those that look and she
knows how dangerous Littlefinger can be
especially now that he has control of an
army the looks on zag a little finger
has been misinterpreted by so many
people Songza didn't give that look
because she thought he was write songs
he gave that look as in what the [ __ ] is
your problem and what are you about to
do the discussion John and Sansa had
told me everything I needed to know
about the future of their relationship
you told me little barely sold you to
the Bolton's he did and he trusted me
I mean fool would trust Littlefinger
should have told you about him about the
Knights of the Vale I'm sorry
we need to trust each other we can't
fight a war amongst ourselves so many
enemies now Sanda will not betray John
and she is done with Littlefinger and
his [ __ ] she is done being lied to
and tricked by Littlefinger Sansa was
genuinely upset that she didn't tell
John about the veil she will take John's
advice about protecting one another she
said herself that you cannot trust
Littlefinger and the look he just gave
her was alarming sons and knows she will
need to act first and act fast
Littlefinger is too dangerous with an
army behind him now and what is one way
songs it can remove little fingers power
but still keep control of the veil how
do you make people fly we don't what you
do a little bad people and the scary
people and people who don't like I never
did anything with them at all
doesn't take part in that where I came
from well I'm lord of the Vale when I
grow up I'll be able to fly anybody who
bothers me or you when we get married
you can tell me if you don't like
somebody and then we can bring them back
here and whoosh break through the moon
door alright sounds fun
by marrying sweet Robin she can keep the
veil for House Stark and remove
Littlefinger from power that's right
Zhaan's is not going to be forced in the
Marian Littlefinger and Arya is not
gonna wear Santa's face to kill him she
wouldn't even need to do that songs our
nose by the look on little fingers face
he is done supporting John the clues
have been there for us to see and
Songz's character arc has already been
set in motion and she is on the rise and
will no longer take two steps back and
development because of what little
fingers actions are Sansa now knows the
rules of the game and what Littlefinger
once and Littlefinger now knows that
manipulating Sansa is a dead end and
he's not going to sit around knowing
that songs deceased through his [ __ ]
Sansa would need to act fast before he
does what he does best which is removing
people from power and Robin is already
willing to marry Sansa and all she needs
to do is explain to Robin what real
happened to his mother liza and say she
kept it a secret because she feared for
her life and i think sweet robin would
understand but little fingers not that
easily outmaneuvered he knows that if he
can't trust sanso what's his secrets
anymore that he's going to be the one
that needs act fast and what the
Littlefinger tell Sansa
he said gold will only buy a man silence
for a short period of time but a bolt to
the heart will buy it forever and Sansa
knows this and knows the information
that she has can get her killed
and what did Tyrion say about Sansa when
his brother Jaime asked about Joffrey's
death Tyrion said Sansa did not kill
Joffrey she is not a killer
not yet which means she is going to
personally kill someone and I'm sure
most of you think that Sansa was the one
who killed Ramsay but she did not
personally kill Ramsay watch that scene
again guys Songza walked up to Jon and
asked him where Ramsay was because she
had no idea where Jon had put him and
when she walked up to the kennels Ramsay
was already there tied up and the kennel
doors were already left open those dogs
were going to eat Ramsay whether sons
who was there or not so Sorensen still
needs to kill someone herself and who
better than Littlefinger I think it
makes a lot more sense for Santi to kill
Littlefinger than it does for Arya to
kill Littlefinger Sansa has that much
more of an emotional connection to
Littlefinger and if you want this death
to be the most satisfying it has to come
by the hands of Sansa that's my opinion
and what did sweet robin say we can
bring the bad man back here we can bring
them back to the Vale and throw them
through the moon door but it's not going
to be Robin who does it what his little
fingers weakness it's a stark woman
Sean's is going to get Littlefinger and
close as if she wants to kiss him this
time and now he goes the Mockingbird
will fly and Sansa Stark will complete
her story arc to now being a strong
woman who deals out her
justice at least that's how I see it
that's what all these clues are telling
me and I'm sure I'm not the only one who
feels this way all the clues are already
out here so you know if other people are
seeing it the same way I do then you're
going to think the same thing and come
to the same conclusion because the signs
are all there for this to happen but now
let's talk about the giveaway but first
like this video please and subscribe to
this channel please that way you guys
are already in position to win the
complete Game of Thrones series
that's right seasons one through six on
blu-ray the whole series the deleted
scenes the extra scenes the history and
lore all that stuff is going to be in
there and one of you will win that just
so I can show my appreciation for how
cool all of you guys have always been to
me but now that I have over 12,000
subscribers I'm no longer going to be
able to use the application that I was
using to randomly select a name so I'm
going to officially announce the
giveaway in my next video and in that
video I'm going to provide a link that
way you guys can have multiple entries
to try to win this prize so keep your
eyes open for my very next video like
this video please subscribe to this
channel if you want to enter I
appreciate all the love I appreciate the
support I appreciate you guys taking all
the time out of your day to listen to
this and I will see you in the comment
section bye